hi there today we'll look at language
models or open knowledge graphs
by chiang wang wang xiao liu and don
song this paper on a high level proposes
to construct
knowledge graphs which is a structured
object that's usually built by human
by experts either fully manually or
semi manually with heavy human
involvement
it proposes to construct knowledge
graphs automatically
by simply using a pre-trained language
model together with a corpus to extract
the knowledge graph from
the cool thing about this paper is that
there is no
training involved so there is no model
that learns how to construct a knowledge
graph
the entire knowledge is simply extracted
from running the corpus once so
one forward pass through the corpus
through the pre-trained language model
and that constructs the knowledge graph
so that's kind of the
the core message of this paper they say
this paper shows how to construct
knowledge graphs from pre-trained
language models without
human supervision and it turns out the
way they do it
it works pretty well on kind of standard
knowledge graph construction
uh benchmarks so that's the the paper in
a nutshell we'll go
through all of this um including i have
a bunch of criticisms
but it is a pre-print uh remember this
and yeah so usually i'd say at this
point
if you like this content don't hesitate
to share it out and so on
today we're gonna try something
different um
in three two one
stop it's sponsor time this video is
sponsored by tab
nine tab nine uses deep learning to help
you
write code faster uh what could possibly
go wrong
if you do that no i'm joking i'm joking
take a look at
this piece of code here i was trying to
refresh some elastic indices
and as you can see here all i said was
could and tap 9 completes it to
could not refresh because above i was
trying to call
a refresh method this is something that
i haven't seen any other completion
engine do
yet compared to a regular coding engine
tab 9 is
trained on lots of open source projects
and it combines
this with your code and it predicts
what you want to do compared to
predicting what's possible which is what
a classic engine does
tap nine it uses a gpt based model
and it downloads that model onto your
machine so the code
never leaves your machine there is an
opt-in feature
where you can run that in the cloud and
that will just give you a bit of a
better beam search and better quality
predictions and it saves you a bit of
ram
as you can see i myself use tab 9. i
just have it on
by default and i'm i'm pretty happy with
it i use it through
coc integrated into my neovim but you
can also get it in
sublime atom intellij vs code even
like jupiter notebooks and you can use
it together
with classic completion engine so you
can really get the best
of both worlds so whenever you see me
code in a coding video
look out for this tn marker next to the
completions that's the
completions by tab 9. it doesn't only
work for python
it actually works for pretty much any
programming language that isn't
completely obscure if you go to this
link within 72 hours of when this video
is released
you'll get three months of tap 9
professional for free
the professional version removes the
project size limit of the free version
and it also gives you access to that
sweet sweet cloud inference
after the three months you're
automatically kicked out of the pro
version
there's no auto sign up there's really
nothing to lose
i mean the only bad thing here is that
top nine itself is written in
rust if that's the worst thing about an
offer it's
it's a pretty good deal again i use this
myself and i'm pretty happy with it so
again
if you sign up at tap nine dot com slash
promotion
slash yannick culture within 72 hours of
when this video is released
you'll get a free three months of tab
nine pro no strings attached and now
enjoy the video
thanks alright i hope that was uh fun
let's get back to the paper let's get
into the paper so first of all
what is my first criticism of this paper
um this the title
there are some disturbing trends
in the last few years in um
in in machine learning papers and the
disturbing trends can be
maybe encapsulated with the phrase is
all you need
so people have
sort of since attention is all you need
since this paper people have discovered
that
if they just append this to whatever
their paper is about
then um the paper will get much more
notoriety
and the same thing i think is a bit at
play here
with this with the r because in recent
times we've kind of seen a bunch of
papers that
show equivalences between models such as
a famous example is that the
transformers
are hotfield networks in some kind of in
some
regard and it these papers are pretty
cool right
even if the two things are not exactly
equal all the time if you can say
look there is a setting there are you
know under these assumptions under these
settings in this situation
these two models actually are the same
that's a pretty cool
recognition pretty cool thing to show
and it's very useful for academia and
and practice i believe however i
i believe the r keyword the is keyword
should be
sort of reserved for when two things are
equivalent
whereas here in the very first at least
they're honest right in the very first
sentence they show they say
well we show how to construct knowledge
graphs from pre-trained language models
so essentially they're going to use a
language model
to approximately construct a knowledge
graph
and they're also going to use a bunch of
other auxiliary models that
come all pre-trained but still they do
not show an equivalence
of language models and knowledge graphs
in this paper not at all
so i would sort of i see
that you can get somewhere with these
titles but
um yeah maybe people will be
disappointed kind of if they read the
paper which
it is actually a cool paper believe me
all right
so as i said what
we have usually is a corpus okay
a corpus is simply a bunch of text
pieces you can think of maybe
just the text in wikipedia okay uh
here you know the the wikipedia page
about bob dylan
bob dylan is a songwriter was awarded a
nobel prize
signed albert grossman these are easy
sentences right there there can be
sentences are usually larger and longer
and so on and what you want to do
is you want to extract a knowledge graph
so the knowledge graph
has two distinct things it has entities
and one ended here would be kind of bob
dylan songwriter is an entity nobel
prize in it is an entity
you can sort of think of them as nouns
okay and then the second part in
knowledge graphs are the relations
here occupation sign award received and
so on
so the relations connect to entities
there is always what's called a head
of an end of a of a triple so a head of
a fact
which in this case is bob dylan three
times
then there is a tail which is sort of
like the object of the
verb and then there is the relation
which is described
by the verb now here you can see
there are two stages of constructing
such a knowledge graph any system that
does this
probably goes through these two stages
so first you extract a set of
candidates which um
it's not the knowledge graph yet because
these are still strings right you
extract a bunch of
string triplets as you can see here
and as we said as the sentences get more
complicated
it gets more and more difficult to
extract these kind of triples and
then the second part is that you need to
map it to a
to a scheme to a to a schema
and these schemas are usually defined by
humans so here we're still going to rely
on humans to define
the schema so there is one list
that says entities and the entities
there are just the entities are listed
okay
by the humans and at some point it says
bob dylan
bob dylan and it has a bunch of mentions
of bob dylan
associated with it and it has a clear id
in this case you see the ide is q392
in that knowledge graph and the
system not only needs to extract these
facts but then also
map these facts to the correct entities
sorry map these facts to the correct
schema
entries this second stage right here
is a a bunch of standard tasks so
especially
mapping something like the the word
dylan
in its context to this entity bob dylan
which you can think of it as like the
wikipedia page of bob dylan
right that's how these systems usually
work that is
a task called entity linking okay
entity linking and similar tasks exist
for for sign like the relation
awarded mapping this to award
received to this uh so maybe there's
some kind of
dictionary entry award received and what
it means and a bunch of examples
and you're supposed to map this to that
these are
standard tasks and the system that we
are going to look at right here
is not con not much concerned with these
tasks
it simply uses pre-existing methods to
do these things
so the system we're looking at today
does this
first part right here it takes text okay
this is text
and it comes up with these candidate
facts about
the text whether or not how this is then
mapped to the schema that is a
a different question and it's so there
are
there are pretty cool things in this
paper about this step
but we're first going to look at the
first step and then at the second step
all right
so how does this system do this and how
does it
do it that there have been machine
learning models before
but being machine learning they all have
like some sort of a training corpus
where you have
kind of the facts as a training set
and then you have a separate set of
facts as a um
test set and you try to learn from the
conjunction of the text
and the training facts how to extract
facts not this system this system
simply uses a pre-trained language model
so what's the reasoning the reasoning is
the following we used to
think that we could do nlp probably best
with having a knowledge graph right with
having this set of
very structured data we can answer
something like
what's the what's the age of
barack obama's wife and then you could
go to the entity of barack obama you
could look at the relation spouse
you could go to michelle obama you could
look up her birth date which would all
be structured information in this graph
so you could sort of answer questions
like this and
search engines like google and so on
they have this
built in so there is kind of a knowledge
graph entry sometimes when you search
an entity in google that pops up
and these have been very useful to
answer questions like this however in
recent years language models have become
better and better
things like birth or gpt2 have become
better than these expert systems let's
call them
at answering questions by the way if you
want
to if you want to hear a very very
cool and solid argument of where these
kind of expert systems where this kind
of structured
human annotated or maybe extracted
information can still come in in natural
language understanding i would recommend
the machine learning street talk episode
we had with wali
sabha extremely interesting person
and i have i i just i can recommend
listening uh to that this should be out
any day
now if it is not already so
the language models have become better
and better at these tasks
without having this structured
information so the hypothesis
is maybe these language models
can already contain the information
that's necessary to construct these
structured
facts because the structured facts is
what we you know let's say should
use to answer these questions because we
feel that
structured information is better than
unstructured the language models are
pretty good at these tasks so maybe
we can get the structured information
out of the language models
so that's what they do they say the
contributions are as follows
we show how to construct knowledge
graphs from pre-trained language models
the large graphs are constructed with a
single forward pass of the pre-trained
language models without fine-tuning over
the textual corpora
i think this is the this is kind of a
very strong point about this paper and
it also shows that
if you're some phd student somewhere and
you don't necessarily have the resources
to train the next gpt3 model
um or even fine tune it there is
still research to be done simply
if if you have enough resources to
forward
pass your data which is often much fewer
than to
train one you can still do very cool
research i think this paper shows this
explicitly
okay this helps researchers explicitly
understand what the language models
learn
bridging the deep language model and the
knowledge graph communities through
enhanced model
transparency okay they say we propose an
unsupervised two-stage approach
mama m-a-m-a which stands for match and
map to first match the candidate facts
in the corpora with the knowledge stored
in language models that's the
first step we looked at then map the
matched candidates facts to both
fixed and open schema to produce a
knowledge
graph and then they say they produce a
new type of knowledge graph
which simply is the the facts sometimes
the facts they extract they can't really
map to a schema
entry and we're going to look at that
because
i think a bit critically of this they
say namely the open knowledge graph
consists of mapped facts
in the fixed schema of existing
knowledge graphs
annotated by humans and the unmapped
facts in the open schema
that are new in the reference knowledge
knowledge graph schema
so what they claim here is that their
system is
finds these new relations that are don't
even exist in the schema
and is able to uncover
kind of build new additional schema
entries and they call this the open
knowledge graph
i'm a bit skeptical of this as we are
going to see
so the first step
how do you come up if you have a
sentence
and this is this is a very poor example
i feel honestly to
to do this it's i get it must be short
but it's a poor example
but stay with me so you have this
sentence dylan is a songwriter
and you would like to extract a fact
from this
the paper is not really written clearly
on how i mean it is i could you can
parse it out
but the description is kind of
distributed
so step one step one
is run spacey
run spacey this is a standard kind of
library for nlp
to extract noun phrases or they call
them noun
chunks okay so step one
is not there's nothing to do with the
language model it is simply
you want to find the noun phrases in
here
the noun phrases are dylan and
songwriter now these noun phrases now
define your head and your tale of the
facts
so you already have two things right so
the the entire task of what of their
method they're proposing
is so step one is run
spacey to find the head and the tail
effects step two
is question mark for now step three
is going to be use the entity linking
system and the relation linking system
to construct the
knowledge graph okay so step one is
steel underpants
and then step three is profit so what's
step two step two
is obviously step two is where their
system comes in
step two is here is the head and here is
the tail
in the text somehow where in between
there might
be a relation and we need to figure out
where that is okay so how does this
method figure it out um
so you already see the assumptions here
are very very
restrictive right so you use spacey to
extract basically noun phrases which
means you're probably already going to
miss a lot of things that are not
recognized as noun phrases and they all
they also say that that
spaces annotations are sometimes error
prone and that's why they miss a lot of
things
and then secondly the assumption that
the relation must be
in between the two things textually now
you can run the algorithm forward and
backward but still it must be in
between and it must sort of be encoded
let's say as a semi accurate string
in there um i guess then that's up to
the relation linker
but already these assumptions are super
constraining
in the the kind of things you can find
and you'll see in the experiments that
their biggest flaw is that they have a
very very low recall i mean so do all
the systems on the task apparently
but they still have a very low recall
and it's because they
constrain their problems so much i'm
going to guess if they wouldn't
constrain their problems so much
then they would have maybe a better
recall but their precision would just
plummet
because uh these these
things if you let them run wild they
just over extract so basically every
every cen every verb in every sentence
is going to be a relation right
so like i ate a banana um
i ate banana would be a triple not
necessarily of
a really uh valuable entry in any
knowledge graph though
banana has a lot of carbs so i would
want to know about that
um okay so you see
that the task is now reduced from
building knowledge graphs to simply
given a head
head annotation head piece
in the string span and the tail
span extract any span
in between the head and the tail that
describes the relation between the head
and the tail
so the way this algorithm does it that's
where it uses the language model
okay so here it's going to do
something that is going to be similar to
dynamic programming
um if you've seen kind of the dynamic
programming
kind of search algorithms let's say um
you know string matching algorithms and
so on this is going to be
sort of similar in that what we're going
to do we're going to start
from here from the head in the string
there could be text before it right
we're simply going to locate the head
dylan right here
and going to start then we're going to
look at its attention
matrix now the attention matrix is we're
going to
cross out here the tension matrix if you
i've done
many many videos and attention the
tension matrix
basically in a sequence means how much
each
token attends to each other token
right how much information is kind of
sent from each other token
to this token right here so this up here
would be
uh be the query and these would be the
keys
the attention matrix specifies that so
since we locate things between the head
and the tail
what we want to do is we want to cross
out we want to disregard everything
that's kind of behind the query
and only look ahead in the sentence
okay so that's why the sum of the
attention matrix here is crossed out
as you can see these are the x's this is
exactly because we only
search in one direction so from each
from the token dylan we can look at
three things we can look at is
a or songwriter and this the question is
simply
where do we go next with this algorithm
right there's no interpretation yet it's
simply
where do we go next and where do we go
next is simply answered by
just taking the highest scoring thing in
that column of the attention matrix i
look at the attention
column where of the token dealer i take
the highest scoring one
that's point three here is higher okay
then i go to point three and that means
is gets
into my candidate fact
and once i put is into my candidate fact
i then go to is so
the next thing i do is i go to is and
then i
again look in the corresponding
attention
column and i see what's now the biggest
entry here
and the biggest entry is 0.4 which is
songwriter and you can see here now we
skip
the a that's how we leave out some text
okay
um by skipping it basically so
you can see that this this can create
artifacts right
this can create like kind of holes in
the middle and so on but we skip a we go
directly to the point four and then we
discover
ah the point four that is our tail
so now we put our tail into
here and since our tail is the last word
we can stop
the algorithm i yeah so so there is no
need to to go on
even if there were texts behind the tail
as soon as we are at the tail which we
already know right we're given the head
and the tail
we stop all right so the we simply go
forward with always the biggest entry in
the attention matrix
until we reach the tail that's the
algorithm
this this there it's described here
but um it's kind of described in this in
this
way where it has these actions
like star yield and like this
maybe i'm not understanding something
but it seems completely unnecessary to
kind of describe these actions
and and basically start the search from
the head the head is added as the
initial candidate and so on
then in yield it sometimes says with the
largest score from the attention matrix
is appended to the end to yield the new
candidate
and so on but
still and then stop we stop
and the algorithm description here it
basically just says
while we're not done if
we're if it's not the stop action we
continue
it's it's sort of it doesn't tell you
anything
like this is this is a super unclear
description of this algorithm
basically the whole logic that you would
want to know about is here in this
action manager
right so the action manager that gives
you the action
is doing the actual logic of figuring
out
which token you know you should do next
and where you should go next and so on
this is nowhere in the algorithm the
algorithm just describes beam search
so you can do this a little yeah the
little more sophistication that comes in
is that you don't do this
deterministically
but you actually do it via beam search
okay
but you can you can just generalize this
all right so the description is a bit
floppy with the whole actions and uh
action manager and whatnot
and not describing the only thing they
don't describe formally is how
actually to select the next token which
is basically the entire
uh kind of meat of the algorithm
in any case you might
this is something that confuses me right
here
so fair enough you know they say here we
take the attention matrix and we cross
out these x's
all right but they say they can
take things up here right they can take
things like
burt and you know as i said fair bert
has a full attention matrix everything
attends to everything
but they can also take things like gpt2
now gpt2 is an autoregressive
language model that means that in gpt2
if you look at it then you produce each
token
one after another which means
that when you produce so
each token when you train
or when you evaluate even each token can
only attend to the things in front of it
right you see the the problem
with what this thing requires oh this is
also the same
okay let's do that you see the problem
with this method this method is the
exact opposite
each token attention matrix is deleted
such that
only the entries ahead of it are
in the attention matrix right you you
don't actually
get gpt2 to give you an attention matrix
that looks ahead because it only ever
looks behind
so maybe maybe what's happening is that
the query and key matrices are
switched up in some way in that case
when we want to interpret the algorithm
the way they write it down is if
i am at a particular part of
what i think is the relation between the
two
uh entities how am i going to find
whether or not there is more to the
relation right there could be
it could be a multi-word relation like
um
has a child with or
i don't know can't think of any
multi-word relations
or whether we kind of are done with the
relation and go
to the to the tail what this thing
is saying is that we should look at the
language model
so if if this is really how it is here
and you are at the word is what you want
to know
if this is bird if this is a birth
language model what you want to know is
if i were to cross out is if i were to
delete this word which other
words in the sentence right here that
are
ahead of me are very very
informative to predict this particular
word
and that's that's kind of the the query
style and
you know if the answer turns out to be
songwriter is quite important for that
maybe dylan is too but we only look
ahead if it turns out
a the word a is not as important as the
word songwriter right because
songwriter yeah it gives an indication
that there should be
is because songwriter is kind of a
profession and there's a person in front
of it
we don't look at that but the attention
matrix would
um would have that in mind that that's
valid
right so that's how this
this construction is made however if
this is the key we have to think of the
other way around if we are at is uh
we look ahead and say if i were to
delete the word
a could i reconstruct it how well could
i reconstruct it from this word
is or if i delete songwriter how well
could i reconstruct
that from the word is i think both are
you know there is interpretations
probably for both of these methods
but what i want kind of to convey is
that
none of these things are really
amenable to constructing a knowledge
graph it's it's
quite interesting that this stuff
actually works because all it
asks is how well does one word inform
about the presence or how well can one
word predict
another word and
from that information we construct this
knowledge graph
which probably is a testament to the
fact that
knowledge graphs maybe aren't so much
about
knowledge um if you extract them from a
corpus but more about grammar
i would think that's a thing that goes
on here because these language models
are
a lot about grammar right a lot about
how
different words appear together
frequently so
given that songwriter is kind of a mix
between grammar and
basic word knowledge given that
songwriter is kind of an object here
the word is being the verb is probably
quite important for it
um and that's exactly these
these triples they always appear a bit
like
in compressed sentences and which which
are very
grammatically relevant so i'm not
buying this hypothesis that there is
much
knowledge in these language models and
that's why this works
what i much rather think is that they
are really really really good at
kind of grammar and statistical
association between words
across the language and that's why they
can extract these candidates facts
so well okay
so that's what i think about the
algorithm they do
constrain it some more as if it doesn't
already have enough constraints
um but they all make sense okay so
they say the matching degree which is
simply the sum
of all these attention matrix entries
that we've encountered during our search
so
all the ones we didn't skip or to
count it together or the matching degree
of this triple
the matching degree must be above some
threshold that's the first constraint
uh because so they give an example right
here
for the sentence rolling stone wrote no
other pop song has so thoroughly
challenged artistic
conventions and the extracted candidate
fact is
rolling stone wrote pop song right
again you can kind of see here it's
mostly going
in into into grammar ish so spacey
extracts
rolling stone and pop song and the
language model here extracts
like the only verb in between wrote
so um yeah to
to limit to kind of limit the
[Music]
the um to limit
the matching degree to say it must be at
minimum
kind of some number it makes a lot of
sense
because if the matching degree is high
that
means if we go by this attention matrix
it means that
these words that are in the candidate
fact
they kind of as themselves they follow
from each other
so the language model thinks that wrote
is a very good follow to rolling stone
and pop song is a very
good follow for rote or the other way
around depending on which way the
attention matrix is but
that's kind of the language model thinks
that
that these words together make sense
um in the context of the sentence of
course like in the context of this
entire sentence
so as i said it's sort of can think of
it as a bit of a summarization
paper but with more constraints
constraint number two is that um
the frequency of r is
above a threshold so the relation itself
shouldn't be too specific it actually
should appear a bunch of times in the
corpus
so what you do is you know you go
through the corpus once extract all the
facts my pen just dropped
you extract all the facts at all all
these candidates and then you
you kind of count them and go through
the
candidate facts again and delete all the
ones that are
below a certain thing that's people
usually do this
with things like stop words or rare
words and so on
it's pretty standard makes a lot of
sense and um
constraint number three relation r is a
contiguous sequence in the
sentence okay so um we have an example
here
from the same rolling stone wrote
challenged conventions
which the language model would like to
extract because again these in the
context of that sentence these words
sort of you know they jump to each other
in the attention matrix because you can
predict
them from each other very well but they
say this must be a contiguous
sequence so what i said before
i said this could happen with this
constraint they
excluded okay
so for the second part where they
actually have to map
a candidate fact to a fact in the schema
as i said they use kind of pre-pre-made
solutions
uh entity linking and relation mapping
with the schema i i won't go
into this except to say that
whenever they find a match
they say that this is a mapped fact
whenever they don't
find a match they say oh this is an
unmapped
fact okay an unmapped candidate means
that at least one of hr t is not mapped
to the schema
there are two types partially unmapped
facts is where
some are mapped and completely unmapped
facts indicate that
all h r and t are not mapped to the
schema
okay for example jacob was a registered
mennonite now here they so they
they say they have these different facts
and you know it's a cool thing if
a model like this can actually come up
with new
facts not so not not only new mapped
facts which
is something you would expect right if
humans provide some kind of a schema
then build a knowledge graph this is
never complete so if you can
automatically
kind of fill in missing facts that's
very very cool though i would say humans
if you construct knowledge graphs humans
should probably also build kind of like
negative connections saying like yes
it is conceivable that uh
elvis was a vegan um because a lot of
texts talk about it but in fact it is
explicitly not i don't think that's what
we
have in the knowledge craft software but
it would be cool
if this model could fill in new facts
yes to the schema it would also be cool
if it could
uncover completely new relations that
haven't hadn't been
considered by the human makers of the
knowledge graph
like if the knowledge graph itself is
incomplete
the schema is a man you know same
argument
the schema is probably also incomplete
this paper is sort of trying to sell
their system as something that can do
that and
i believe that to a degree but also also
jacob was a registered mennonite
okay now maybe i'm completely
wrong from the sentence jacob was a
registered mennonite in amsterdam
i might be completely wrong but
mennonite is a religion
i think and um
i'm very very sure that any of these
knowledge graphs with the
schema that they have have
being in a religion or being of a
certain faith
in their relations table somewhere and
i'm also pretty sure that mennonite
large enough that that would actually
appear as an entity maybe jacob not
right maybe jacob is an
unknown jacob we don't know who jacob is
um but this seems more like a failure
of the entity linker and relation
linker than an uncovered new
relation or an uncovered new uh entity
so yeah take this
stuff with a grin now they they are very
honest about this
but just to say that
that's probably what happens most often
so here you can see
the graph for bob dylan constructed from
the wikipedia pages
that are kind of out they say around the
page of bob dylan so i guess
one or two or three hops away something
like this
and you can see the blue stuff is stuff
that we already knew
so that the human humans also found when
looking at this
then yellow stuff i believe is either
new relations so whenever things are
annotated it's a new relation in the
schema
so you can see this is an entity in the
schema because it's annotated this is a
relation in the schema
but the arrow is new so
the humans hadn't yet extracted the fact
that bob dylan was or
was a member of artists united against
apartheid
um then the yellow also sometimes means
that there is a new thing so here tour
with is a relation that's extracted
that is not in the knowledge graph yet
also this one and you can it's pretty
it's pretty cool
right that you can extract these things
automatically there's a lot of yellow
stuff here which means there's not a lot
of new information
that this extracted and a lot of this
new information is actually mapped to
the schema right
bob dylan residence in duluth
i don't know how to pronounce that by
the way
yes so so that's that's fairly fairly
cool they do uh some of these tasks of
these knowledge-based tasks so in these
tasks what you'd have
i believe what you'd have is always
you'd have like a head
and a relation given
so you have a document and you
are given a head and a relation and
you're asked
what's the tale of this right and then
you ask the system and the system will
tell you so you have these baselines and
these baselines i believe they are
specifically made to extract these
knowledge
representations they might even be
trained i don't i don't know that
but you can see that the mama even
even the smallest one here
beats those by quite a bit now you can
see
that the recall is significantly lower
than the precision
which is a direct result of how many
constraints on the system
there are and tells you sort of
what the going forward what the
improvements
can be so they analyze a lot of this
and yeah so a first recognition is that
larger and deeper language models
produce knowledge graphs of higher
quality
bert language models outperform gpt2
language models under similar model
sizes which
is interesting
is scalable to larger corpora which
again as we said you don't need to train
it
and larger corpora embed more complete
knowledge graphs which is
something we would expect the other
interesting part is the unmapped facts
so the numbers you can
actually compute only for the mapped
facts right because that's where you
have data humans produce
the knowledge graphs from this that's
what you can compare with
now the unmapped facts they say they
analyze we turn to study the quality of
the candidate facts that are not
mapped to the above reference knowledge
graph schema but are in the open schema
generated by mama
let's mama we manually judge such on map
facts generated by
our best method from 100 sample
documents in wikidata
and tac kbp respectively so they they go
as researchers they look at these things
and they judge them
whether or not they're true given these
documents in wikipedia
they say the quality of unmapped facts
is verified
um so the the claim is that they've
looked at them
and they are good we find that 35.3
percent of the unmapped facts are true
on wikidata we find that 83.2
of those true facts are partially
unmapped facts
um for example bob dylan tour with the
grateful dead
and yeah here is an ex if this really
isn't
in the schema right this is a nice
relation that you
might think humans would miss because
touring with someone is not the first
thing that would come to mind if you
had to come up with a bunch of relations
between entities but it is something
that is
regularly useful regularly used for
musicians
so that is an application where
certainly an automated system
can even extend the schema right um
user relation is not within the scheme
of wikidata
while both head and tail are in the
schema the register
the remaining true facts are completely
unmapped
facts for example this red jacob was a
registered mennonite
and they also say accurate entity
detection is desired
where they say a lot of the errors are
due to
spacey detecting uh wrong incorrect
entities or
due to incorrect or missing entity
linking
by the by that those systems
the rest errors made by mama are
incorrect relation phrases
such as uninformative relation phrases
for example bob dylan made and his
breakthrough
oh what can you do what other what other
one
what other verb would you put there um
yeah
but okay we're going to look at a few
last things right here they have a bunch
of um
a bunch of experiments right here which
where they show you know the beam size
has an influence this constraint number
one and number two
that we looked at has an influence right
so
you can tune these things a bit what is
interesting here is that they try
they try to look at either the attention
matrix of the last
or of all the layers and interestingly
the system performs better if you only
look at the attention matrix in the last
layer
now they reduce that attention layer
because there are multiple heads using
max or mean you can see they perform
similarly
but it is interesting that only the last
and they argue
they argue in the text that we know that
the last layers kind of have
higher level features than the lower
layers but i recall
uh there are multiple papers like i've
done videos about them
what does bert learn and so on i think
even something in
constrain in conjunction with lottery
tickets and so on
that show that in a transformer at least
i think it is the middle layers
that encode the most kind of semantic
knowledge
because the lower ones yes they are for
kind of low level features but the upper
ones
they are again for low level features
because the task
right here at the end is to predict
an individual word or token right so
you'd expect that the features in the
attention matrix there go back to kind
of sort of more grammatical
features and so on and that the highest
level features are actually
somewhere in the middle i don't know if
they tested if they only tested like all
versus last
in which case yeah i believe that um but
if they
tested each one individually and it
still turned out that last is the best
that would kind of add to my hypothesis
that what happens here is more kind of a
grammatical effect of extracting
the this correct candidate candidate
verb
in between the head and the tail all
right
so that's that's kind of kind of gives
more weight to my hypothesis like
so to to repeat my hypothesis is that
it's kind of a grammatical thing that's
going on here
uh because the only task of this model
is basically to find the correct
um string span for the relation between
head and tail
because it's already given head and tail
and there
from the text their hypothesis is more
like um
we the language models have a lot of
knowledge built into them and we can
extract that knowledge kind of
it they make it sound like the language
model has this semantic knowledge
in them okay okay so so
let's look at a bunch of mapped facts
right here
um you can okay
you can maybe check out a lot of them
yourself
but we'll just look at like one in each
category
blah blah blah's mail yada yada yada is
in worse shape however
klaus told press conference at the
western city of essen where
yada yada and it extracts
this company and it maps it to
the city of headquarters maybe they
leave out some text here
what i want to get to is the unmapped
facts where are the unmapped mapped
facts
to just kind of show you mapped facts
unmapped facts okay so the unmapped
facts would i feel
and you can judge for yourself please
what i feel
uh just to pre-bias you before we look
at them is that
a lot of times simply
it extracts things that are
that are um
it extracts things that are not
it simply can't can't assign things
right it's a failure to assign it's not
a new thing because
in these schemas like you haven't seen
the schemas but you kind of get a feel
the last which is the last table you
kind of get a feel of what
contains in it so
maybe get a feel for for what okay
aaron's tackle was born 16th of february
1834 in potsdam
okay so the extracted thing is
heckle was born on 17th of february 83
in potsdam okay so that
it maps to this is in the knowledge base
a schema this is in the schema but was
born on 17th of february 1833 in
is simply a failure of the relation
linker
okay um
he was also a pacifist until the first
world war yada yada yada
um and then ernst heckle
and then was and a and a pacifist are
both not in the schema now
maybe pacifism isn't in the schema
maybe maybe though i would guess
pacifism
has a wikipedia page so it must be in
this schema because it's a wiki data
but was as you know the relation here
with something be like
a political leaning or something like
this which is
certainly certainly in the knowledge
base right then you have things like
um heckle was awarded the
title of excellency so you have
correctly
heckle again recognized a word received
is in the schema
nice excellency as a tale and
excellency you know what what do you
want
like this is this this is a
this is not a fact right this is
the award or the title of excellency
would be kind of the thing so this is a
failure of
spacey so again i have i've seen little
facts here
that would actually um be
of genuine a genuine addition to the
schema that should be considered
and i absolutely believe that the schema
is incomplete don't get me wrong i
like at 100 the schema is probably
less than one percent of what it should
be right if we did a thorough job
i just don't think that this system here
is um a good like
i think that the things that this system
comes up with mostly
are simply failures of its
subsystems rather than genuinely
new entries to the schema that's
different
from when it genuinely discover when it
discovers a new mapping between already
established things
for example pauline baines educated at
this college right so these are new
facts
all fit in the schema and the system
might be very very nice for that
all right so that was my uh kind of
estimation of this paper i hope i didn't
drag on it too much as i said it's
it's very cool work actually um
i look at this appendix is giant go look
at it
uh check it out please uh tell me what
you think about it in the comments
any feedback is welcome and i
will see you next time bye